En el aprendizaje no gustan las preguntas.
Los maestros no nos
enseñan a cuestionarnos.
Nos dicen cómo son las cosas
y cómo debemos responder.
En mi vida siempre ha habido
espacio para las preguntas.
Tanto las que me he hecho yo
como las que me han hecho los demás.
De hecho, cuando me invitaron
a hablar sobre educación informal
hubo una pregunta fija en mi cabeza
y que quería compartir con vosotros:
¿Por qué siempre que detienen al Equipo A
lo encierran en un garaje?
Estoy seguro de que vosotros
también lo habéis pensado alguna vez.
Para los más jóvenes:
el Equipo A es una serie de los 80
donde un grupo de ex militares
de lo más variopinto
ayudaban a una comunidad en peligro.
En todos los capítulos eran capturados
y metidos en un granero,
un almacén o un garaje,
y en todos los capítulos
utilizaban las herramientas y materiales
que encontraban en el garaje para escapar.
Yo me preguntaba:
¿por qué los meten otra vez en un garaje?
¿No ven que está lleno
de cosas alucinantes?
Pero los malos no terminaban de verlo.
Para ellos era un lugar donde dejar
objetos inútiles, cosas abandonadas,
un lugar donde dejar la basura.
Hace poco leí que la basura es el producto
del límite de la imaginación.
Y esa es la diferencia entre
los malos y el Equipo A,
donde los malos veían
una masa abstracta de objetos,
el Equipo A veía un paraíso
lleno de posibilidades.
Supongo que por eso años después,
el taller donde trabajo con mis compañeros
tiene este aspecto,
de hecho si os fijáis algunos de ellos
podrían estar en la serie.
(Risas)
El caso es que al terminar cada capítulo,
el líder del Equipo A
se ponía un puro entre los dientes
y decía muy pichi:
"Me encanta que los planes
salgan bien".
Y yo me preguntaba:
pero ¡¿qué planes?!
Os atrapan, caéis en una trampa,
os encierran en un garaje
y escapáis de milagro.
Pero algo de razón sí que tenía.
Isaac Asimov, otro tipo
lleno de preguntas, decía:
"Para triunfar,
el mero planteamiento es insuficiente.
Es necesaria la improvisación".
Si lo dice Isaac Asimov
algo tendrá de razón.
El caso es que eso era justo
lo que hacía el Equipo A: improvisar.
Eran capaces de aunar
sus capacidades, sus destrezas,
sus valores y combinarlos para
enfrentarse a diversas situaciones.
En definitiva, eran capaces de
poner en práctica sus competencias.
Llevo siendo educador salvaje
casi la mitad de mi vida.
Educador porque no entiendo
otra forma de ver la vida
que no sea a través
del aprendizaje compartido.
Salvaje porque solo sé
pensar con las manos.
Es decir, reflexionar
cuando me pongo a hacer.
Frente a un límite, una barrera,
lo primero que pienso
es cómo desbordarla.
Como hacían los bárbaros
con el muro de Adriano.
Todo esto lo aprendí
en mi casa.
Mis padres son maestros
y llenaban las sobremesas
de conversaciones sobre alumnos,
claustros, modelos educativos...
Yo, como buen hijo de maestros,
me convertí en un alumno modelo.
Terminé lo que era COU,
que ahora es secundaria,
con matrícula de honor.
Luego entré en la Universidad
y tardé 14 años en terminar la carrera.
(Risas)
De arquitectura.
Yo puedo reconocerle a mis padres
hoy, aquí, delante de todos,
que no me metí en la tuna,
que tampoco fui
campeón de mus.
Tuve la suerte de coincidir
con otros compañeros
que como yo, decidieron
dejar de lado el plan establecido,
improvisar y
buscar otras opciones.
Durante estos 14 años,
junto con mis compañeros,
he llevado a cabo proyectos
en los cuatro continentes
y me han invitado a
dar charlas y cursos
en universidades
de todo el mundo.
¿Cómo puede ser que
una universidad
contrate a un tipo que
solo tiene el título de Bachillerato
para dar una clase?
¿Es un fallo del sistema?
¿O es una manera que tiene el sistema
de corregir ciertas carencias?
Volvamos al Equipo A.
Puedes ser
un piloto excepcional,
un mecánico maravilloso e incluso
disparar mejor que Lucky Luke,
pero si no eres capaz de
trabajar en equipo,
detectar los problemas y
plantear soluciones creativas
nunca saldrás de ese garaje.
En definitiva,
la capacidad para improvisar
pertenece al ámbito
de las competencias.
¿Cómo se adquieren
esas competencias?
Bueno,
en primer lugar,
la educación sucede
a lo largo y ancho de la vida.
No empieza en la escuela
ni termina cuando acabas un máster.
Por decirlo
de otra manera,
¿cómo aprendes antes inglés?
¿Apuntándote a
la escuela de idiomas
o echándote una novia irlandesa?
(Risas)
¿Cómo aprendes sobre mecánica?
¿En un módulo de
Formación Profesional
o tuneando la furgoneta
con tus colegas?
En el fondo es una pregunta trampa.
Es decir, ambos aprendizajes
son complementarios y necesarios.
El aprendizaje informal
no es una versión "low cost"
del aprendizaje formal.
El aprendizaje informal es
el motor vital que nos permite
articular el deseo y la curiosidad,
que es lo que alimenta
nuestras ganas de saber.
Estamos diseñados genéticamente
para aprender durante toda la vida.
A menos que se nos cruce en el camino
un sistema educativo perverso.
Como, por ejemplo,
un sistema que nos obliga
a memorizar las respuestas
en lugar de ayudarnos a preguntarnos.
¿Podemos recuperar la ilusión
después de atravesar estas situaciones?
Estamos acostumbrados a sistemas
que aúnan un grupo de reglas y leyes
a través de las cuales se decide
qué es valido y qué no lo es.
Y las personas que no son capaces
de adaptarse a ese sistema
acaban siendo rechazadas.
¿Podemos crear un sistema
que se adapte a las características
de las personas y que les permita
desarrollarse con todo su potencial?
¿Cómo?
A lo largo de estos 14 años como educador,
me he dado cuenta de que
es más fácil de lo que parece.
En primer lugar,
tenemos que crear estados de excepción.
Pequeños gestos
que nos saquen de la rutina
y que nos permitan
transformar un espacio anodino
en un espacio mágico donde
lo inesperado pueda tener lugar.
Por ejemplo llenar la escuela
de arquitectura de basura
y promover un concurso
de construcción creativa durante un día.
O llenar la Plaza del 2 de mayo en Madrid
con pelotas de plástico.
También puede ser que
llenemos el patio del Conde Duque,
cerca de aquí,
de ropa de segunda mano.
Lo sorprendente fue cuando
la gente empezó a disfrazarse,
empezaron a atar la ropa
unos con otros,
formando unas grandes cuerdas
con las que jugaban a saltar la comba.
Durante unas horas
el patio del Conde Duque
se convirtió en un patio de recreo.
No hace falta algo tan sofisticado.
A veces basta colgar un columpio
en una avenida en Sao Paulo
para poder sentir la ingravidez.
¡Ojo! No confundamos espacios salvajes
con espacios domesticados.
No confundamos el zoo con la jungla,
las oficinas de Google con un taller
o televisión con Internet.
Nosotros buscamos espacios mágicos,
que nos emocionen,
nos sorprendan,
nos estimulen,
pero también donde podamos
actuar, crear, activarnos.
Espacios donde podamos
trabajar valores universales
de una manera natural.
Por ejemplo,
podemos hablar de género
mientras construimos nubes
con bolsas y cartones de segunda mano
para la ciudad de El Cairo.
Podemos, también,
hablar sobre integración racial
mientras construimos
un océano de plástico
que señale los problemas ecológicos
en las costas de Sudáfrica.
No tenemos que irnos tan lejos.
Aquí, en el sur de Madrid,
en san Cristóbal de los Ángeles,
un grupo de vecinos,
mayores, niños,
ancianos, jóvenes,
adultos,
se juntan y se reconocen
sus capacidades
mientras recuperan un espacio abandonado
y lo transforman en un centro cultural
y además educativo.
¿Podemos traducir, transformar
estos espacios salvajes
y llevarlos a espacios reglados?
Un estudio en
30 colegios de Cataluña
decía que el patio
es de los pocos, si no el único,
lugar diseñado exclusivamente para
el recreo y la diversión de los niños
y que, además, está dentro
de un centro educativo.
Es más, los niños pasaban unos
30 minutos al día en ese recreo,
lo que hacía unas 525 horas al año
más que asignaturas o materias
como Educación para la ciudadanía
o Lengua Extranjera.
Es decir, el tiempo de recreo
se ha convertido
en un espacio importantísimo
para la formación de los alumnos
en los centros educativos reglados.
Este mismo estudio
se preguntaba:
cómo puede ser
que en los últimos 90 años
estos patios apenas hayan evolucionado.
¿Podemos transformar
espacios domésticos
en espacios mágicos?
¿Podemos hacerlo juntos?
Alumnos, profesores,
padres, madres, administración...
¿Cómo lo haríamos?
¿Qué necesitamos?
Yo aquí seguiría un poco
la estela del Equipo A.
Tenemos alrededor
casi todo lo que necesitamos.
Por ejemplo, en un campo de refugiados
en Palestina, en Suf, Jordania
nos juntamos para,
durante tres días,
reutilizar lonas y neumáticos
y construir una zona de recreo
y un espacio de sombras.
En Addis Abeba,
en Etiopía,
tuvimos una semana
para convertir ese espacio
en una zona de juegos
y un aula al aire libre.
En Níger, en Niamey,
un grupo de voluntarios
de estos centros culturales
se juntaron para aprender
a diseñar y construir
el primer patio de recreo
público del país,
sin ninguna experiencia previa
y transformando el espacio
donde antes quemaban residuos
en una zona de juegos.
La mera transformación morfológica
de los patios no es suficiente.
El modelo pedagógico
tiene que estar presente.
No podemos perder
una oportunidad única
para desarrollar y trabajar competencias
que normalmente se quedan en los márgenes.
Por ejemplo,
las inteligencias múltiples,
la responsabilidad compartida,
los equipos colaborativos
y eso es lo que hemos estado haciendo
estos últimos años en colegios en Madrid.
Transformar el patio desde esos valores.
Lo hemos hecho desde
Las Tablas hasta Caño Roto.
Si os fijáis, todos estos ejemplos
que os estoy mostrando
tienen una cosa en común:
son objetos abstractos.
Porque, al final del día, una canasta
te obliga a jugar al baloncesto
y una portería
te obliga a jugar al fútbol.
Pero un bidón de 25.000 litros...
te obliga a pensar.
(Risas)
¡Y mucho!
Y te obliga a imaginar.
Y te obliga a preguntarte.
Si a mí me preguntaran ahora
dónde encerraría al Equipo A
para tenerlos allí de por vida,
no diría un garaje.
Diría antes unos laboratorios,
unas oficinas,
unas aulas,
incluso una clase en Harvard.
El caso es que, las sobremesas,
me dejaron algo en la cabeza
que tampoco he podido quitarme.
Y es que, como educadores,
tenemos la obligación de soñar.
Y de crear espacios donde cada uno
tenga la oportunidad de ser
la mejor versión de sí mismo.
Muchas gracias.
(Aplauso)